“What about this one?” one SCP researcher
called to the other.
“You’ve got to be kidding,” his colleague
scoffed, interpreting the suggestion as little
more than a joke.
“That thing’s a piece of junk.”
She tapped a knuckle against the glass case,
catching the attention of the tiny figure
inside.
“Who dares?”
exclaimed a tinny, monotone voice.
“Release me from this irksome confinement
so that I may bring about your final undoing,
vermin!
For I am DoomBot 2000, the ultimate bringer
of destruction.”
Both researchers laughed at the small automaton
inside the glass.
They had come to SCP Item Gallery 27 in search
of non-organic anomalies to gather for testing,
but judging by their reactions, it seemed
that SCP-1370 wasn’t going to make the cut.
The cobbled-together robot was widely considered
to be a harmless, clumsy little oddity, rather
than any kind of threat.
But that didn’t stop SCP-1370 from challenging
any and all things around it to a battle to
the death.
Battles it always lost.
“This thing is junk,” the second researcher
remarked, flicking her finger at the glass
again in an attempt to startle the robot.
“It’s not organic, though,” the other
pointed out, observing that SCP-1370 had been
constructed out of various recycled parts.
Its head was a defunct and non-operational
voltmeter, soldered awkwardly onto a weak
neck joint.
Its arms were wrenches, and it had been configured
in such a way that gave the robot a top-heavy,
impractical design.
“Inorganic, yes, but worth our time?
Definitely not.
Come on, we’ll find something else to test
in SCP-914.”
As the pair of researchers turned their backs
on SCP-1370, it began to squawk at them again
through the speaker embedded in its chest.
“You dare walk away from me?
You have incurred the wrath of RoboLord the
Destructor, and will soon be reduced to atoms
by my hand!”
The tiny junk robot charged towards the two
Foundation personnel, only to slam front-first
into the glass of the display case it was
kept contained in.
The force of the impact, combined with SCP-1370’s
imbalanced design, caused it to topple over
and land on its back, leaving a huge crack
in the glass.
“Oh great,” one of the researchers sighed,
rolling her eyes.
“We’re going to have to report that SCP-1370’s
damaged its case again.
Come on, let’s go and get someone to replace
that glass.”
“You think we should just leave it here
unsupervised in a damaged case?” the other
asked.
“Look at the thing, it’s hardly competent
enough to escape,” the fellow researcher
replied, as the tiny robot struggled to get
itself back upright.
“I’m sure it’ll be fine for a few minutes.”
Little did the pair of researchers realize
as they left Item Gallery 27, that SCP-1370
had been listening to their conversation,
picking up on a few details.
While the anomalous automaton often displayed
a low level of intelligence and awareness
of its surroundings, it was still self-aware.
And on top of that, harbored a hatred for
all things it believed to be living; although
it could easily be tricked, and lacked any
kind of real fighting ability.
But it had picked up on something the researchers
had mentioned, an ‘SCP-914’.
Perhaps through its own limited intelligence
or some other kind of anomalous awareness,
the tiny robot detected this to mean another
machine.
And so, standing back up, it struck the glass
of its display case again, shattering one
side completely.
It hopped down to the ground, tumbling over
thanks to its lack of balance, only to eventually
stand back up and start making its way through
the facility.
Being only a meter tall made it easy for SCP-1370
– otherwise known as ‘PesterBot’ – to
sneak through the corridors of the Foundation
site undetected.
It eventually arrived at a room housing a
large mass of gears and gyros, a machine filled
with clockwork components that seemed to pull
the little robot further in as it drew closer
and closer to what the researchers had spoken
of.
SCP-914, the Clockworks, a device that could
be used to refine any object placed inside
it.
Depending on the setting, items could be transformed,
destroyed, or vastly improved using the Clockworks.
‘Rough’ setting disintegrated any test
subject, while ‘Coarse’ dismantled it
to its base components.
‘1:1’ replaced any item with an almost
identical copy.
Then, the ‘Fine’ setting would cause SCP-914
to improve any item, and ‘Very Fine’ could
refine an object to an even greater degree,
usually by granting it anomalous properties.
Testing of all biological matter within SCP-914
was strictly prohibited, but PesterBot…
well, he was made of metal.
Sneaking into the room where the Clockworks
was located, SCP-1370 immediately caught sight
of another Foundation researcher, who had
been busy overseeing tests using the Very
Fine setting of SCP-914.
Instantly, the agitated little robot made
a beeline for the researcher, swiping at her
ankles with its wrench hands.
“Die, die!”
it shrieked.
“Cower before the might of my claws, none
can stand before the relentless destruction
brought forth by ShivaTron, Despoiler of Mirth!”
referring to itself with one of its many elaborate,
self-appointed titles.
Caught by surprise at the tiny robot, the
researcher turned and screamed in surprise.
Instinctively, she swung her leg back and
brought it forward, delivering a swift kick
to SCP-1370 that sent its metal body hurtling
through the air… right into the Clockworks.
PesterBot landed inside the ‘Input’ booth,
the enormous collection of clockwork components
whirring and heaving as they sprung to life.
The researcher hadn’t even realized what
was happening.
She’d been addressing how much her foot
hurt after kicking the small metal robot.
By the time she looked up, SCP-914 had already
fully activated with SCP-1370 inside.
In horror, she sounded the alarm to summon
security, with no idea what the ‘Very Fine’
setting would do to improve the PesterBot.
A team of guards filed into the room, drawing
their weapons and training them on the Output
booth of the Clockworks.
While they normally would have nothing to
fear from SCP-1370, given its inability to
ever win a fight that it started.
Even when fighting a potted plant that had
been affixed with a speaker, the tiny robot
had been bested.
But the Clockworks refinement process meant
that what would be stepping out of the machine
wouldn’t be the PesterBot the Foundation
was familiar with.
Sure enough, the heavy foot that came stomping
down on the facility floor was a far cry from
the flimsy metal limbs SCP-1370 had previously
had.
Out of the Clockworks emerged a hulking robotic
form, not just bigger and bulkier than the
meter tall, clumsily assembled PesterBot,
but a huge, sleek machine built for bear.
It was more humanoid, but stood at nearly
seven feet tall.
The weight imbalance issued that had plagued
the previous design were seemingly gone, as,
despite its increased size, this new and improved
model of SCP-1370 seemed to move fluidly,
with smooth, electronic motions.
The robot turned and assessed its surroundings,
scanning the group of Foundation security
that had amassed outside SCP-914: its first
new targets.
As the machine stepped towards them, the security
commander gave the word, and the guards opened
fire.
A hail of gunfire rang out, deafening shots
ringing in the security officers’ ears as
bullets spat out of their weapons toward the
newly refined PesterBot.
By the time each of them had emptied their
magazines, and the smoke cleared, they realized
to their terror, that the robot was now bulletproof.
“You have engaged in an act of violence
against Doom-Master Thirteen Seventy, Master
of All Doom,” it announced in a new voice,
one far deeper and more imposing than its
previous tinny candor; now it was a modulated,
electronic sound, far befitting its new look.
“Prepare to face consequences.
Retaliating.”
With that, the robot leaped into battle with
all the grace and ferocity of a wild cat.
The nearest security guard barely had a chance
to reload his weapon, raising his hands in
a weak attempt at a block before the strike
from a metallic fist knocked the wind out
of him.
Moving with balletic speed and precision,
the PesterBot swiped and chopped at the guard,
each hit connecting painfully with one of
the man’s vital pressure points, like it
was a highly trained hand-to-hand fighter.
When the officer collapsed, unable to move
save for letting out screams of excruciating
pain, the robot turned to face its remaining
targets.
“Freeze!”
one of the Foundation security yelled, raising
his pistol with shaking hands.
Zipping forwards, SCP-1370 grabbed the gun
and wrenched it from the man’s fingers,
tearing the weapon apart like it was made
of cardboard.
Gripping the man by his SCP Foundation uniform,
it launched him directly upwards, sending
his body crashing through the ceiling, leaving
a human-shaped hole above.
Chunks of building materials rained down on
the robot, including wiring, and internal
lengths of cable that ran through the walls
and ceiling that were now exposed.
As the security team retreated, SCP-1370 curiously
reached up and gripped one of the electric
cables, wrenching it out of the ceiling to
examine it closer, causing sparks to shower.
The PesterBot’s new sleek, metallic skin
seemed to react to the metal in the wiring,
drawing out the copper that channeled electricity
throughout the Foundation facility.
It was more than a force of magnetism, it
was something else…
ideas, SCP-1370 was learning, adapting, and
most frighteningly of all, coming up with
new ways to complete its purpose.
Marching up to the nearest wall, it pulled
back a metal fist and sent it slamming through
paintwork and plaster, to draw out the metal
running through the building.
Outside in the corridor, the lights died.
In fact, the entire facility lost its power,
and plunged into darkness until the backup
emergency lighting activated, filling the
Foundation’s corridors with low-level, blood-red
light.
More security officers had mobilized to outside
the Clockworks room, expecting any moment
that the refined version of the previously
harmless PesterBot would soon appear.
Sure enough, it did, and the red lighting
was soon added to by yet another hail of frightened
gunfire.
But now, it seemed SCP-1370 had learned how
to shoot back.
An arc of lightning zapped through the corridor,
electrifying every guard it touched and reducing
them to little more than a smoldering husk.
A second one followed, striking one guard
with a bolt of blue electricity that then
leaped from his body to the officer standing
next to him, who had been close enough to
touch his fallen comrade, and who was, of
course, wearing plenty of conductive metal.
The wiring in the walls, the electricity,
SCP-1370 had learned how to weaponize it.
And that wasn’t all.
As the robot stepped out of the room, it had
pulled various other metalwork from the fabric
of the building around it into its form, adding
to its body in new and gruesome ways.
Its shoulders now had additional armor; long
poles of rebar now extended out of its robotic
forearms to act as crude, rudimentary impaling
weapons – it had even gotten taller.
And all forged out of metal it had harvested
from its surroundings.
SCP-1370 hadn’t just been made a better
fighter, it had been given something else
by SCP-914.
Intelligence, the capacity for it to learn
and perpetually adapt itself.
And it wouldn’t stop, it would keep improving
itself to enact its original purpose: to fight
anything and everything around it.
A slaughter ensued, everything the SCP Foundation
threw at this new version of the PesterBot
only gave it more weapons, and more offensive
capabilities to add to its growing arsenal.
The rebar weapons in its arms were replaced
with sleek, sharp blades, even bullets fired
at it seemed to be absorbed into its mass,
allowing it to keep growing.
SCP-1370 was unstoppable, obliterating everyone
that came to desperately try to contain it.
And as it bested every opponent, left them
decimated and defeated, something else new
happened to the robot.
It couldn’t feel emotions, just like with
any automaton, it lacked the level of human
cognition and complexity to respond to things
with feelings.
But as it killed more and more Foundation
staff left and right, annihilating everything
in its path, SCP-1370 experienced something.
Not an emotion, but whatever the closest robotic
equivalent to pure, unbridled happiness was.
Satisfaction of the machine, now able to complete
the function it was originally built for,
yet had failed at for so long.
Getting bigger and bigger, adapting and adding
more machines to itself, eventually SCP-1370
was a hulking behemoth.
Cars, and their combustion engines all became
part of the robotic giant, every new piece
of technology it encountered becoming a deadly
weapon.
And as PesterBot started to tower over buildings,
a huge-scale robotic threat, the Foundation
had no choice.
It was time to deploy another big, bad bot
to cut SCP-1370 back down to size.
It was time to send in the Dragonslayer.
Now go check out “WHAT IF SCP-096 WAS PUT
INSIDE SCP-914?”, where the Shy Guy is refined
into…
well, you’ll have to click and see!
And “SCP-914 WHAT DID YOU PUT IN IT?!”
to see what happened when we opened up the
Clockworks to you, the fans!